I always had the idea
that I wanted to work for a company
maybe in the financial world.
Maybe I was somehow biased and affected
by movies like "Wall Street."
So, I grew up in Italy
and watching movies like "Wall Street"
where movies that were picturing
this image of successful people
managing in a very successful business environment,
and it was something that was really intriguing,
only to find out later on
that the world is not exactly
what you see in those movies.
But I guess I had a clear idea
that I was very attracted by a career
in an international environment
and an environment where corporate challenges
were probably one of the things
that would have interested me.
So, I think it turned out
that things were not so much different
from what I projected when I was in grade school.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.